FASTER HELP, THE INCREMENT OF
HELP WILL SAVE THE LIVES OF
UKRAINIANS AND REGAIN THE
TERRITORIES OCCUPIED BY RUSSIA.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN AT TIMES
EXTREMELY CRITICAL OF THE MIXED
MESSAGES OF NATO.
WHAT'S IT LIKE TO WATCH NATO TO
EMBRACE SWEDEN AND FINLAND AFTER
UKRAINE IS TRYING TO JOIN NATO
WITHOUT SUCCESS AT LEAST SO FAR?
>> Translator: FIRSTLY, I'M VERY
HAPPY THAT FINLAND AND SWEDEN
WILL BECOME NATO MEMBERS.
IT IS EASIER.
IT IS MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD.
MORE CLEVER THAN THE BLOODY WAR.
THE ACCEPTANCE OF FINLAND AND
SWEDEN IS JUST A PREVENTIVE
MEASURE TO KEEP RUSSIA FROM
INVADING THOSE TERRITORIES AND
PEOPLE.
THIS IS WHY WE SUPPORT 100% THE
DECISION OF THE WORLD AND THOSE
COUNTRIES.
IT IS A MUTUAL DECISION.
RESPECT AND UNDERSTANDING.
IT IS NOT SUPERFICIAL BUT DEEP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE RISKS FOR
THESE COUNTRIES WITH THE
AGGRESSIVE ATTITUDE OF RUSSIA TO
SOVEREIGN COUNTRIES.
THAT IS WHY WE'RE FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THEIR MEMBERSHIP.
THE WHOLE WORLD IS HELPING
UKRAINE.
SOME DOING HUMANITARIAN AID,
SOME FINANCIAL OR MILITARY AID.
BOTH HOUSES IN THE UNITED STATES
SUPPORT US.
THE WORLD IS DOING A LOT.
BUT IT COULD HAVE BEEN EASIER.
UKRAINE COULD HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED
AS A NATO MEMBER.
IT WOULD BE MUCH MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD THAN PEOPLE
IMAGINE.
THAT'S WHY I'M NOT SULKING
BECAUSE OF THIS.
THAT WE ARE NOT MEMBERS OF NATO.
THIS IS A JOINT DECISION.
YOU KNOW, ALWAYS IN EVERYTHING
YOU USE A SHORT CUT.
I DON'T LOOK FOR A SHORT CUT.
NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
AND NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
SECURITY GUARANTEES AND THE
SUPPORT AND IT COULD HAVE BEEN
SO MUCH EASIER JUST TO ACCEPT
UKRAINE AS A MEMBER OF NATO.
THIS IS ALREADY BEING DISCUSSED.
DURING THE LATEST NATO MEETING
THEY ALL, THE MEMBERS, AGREED TO
SUPPORT UKRAINE.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
OTHERWISE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
CYNICISM.
I UNDERSTAND THIS DECISION BUT
THEY ALWAYS FOUND REASONS BEHIND
NOT ACCEPTING UKRAINE.
I ONLY CAN SAY THAT ACCEPT